speaking of clueless actresses
jessica biel posted one of my
favorite social media posts that i've
seen in
days i don't know there's really good
stuff coming out these days because the
libs are so clueless they're so behind
the ball here it was a picture of
jessica beale
with her husband justin timberlake in
front of the eiffel tower
she tweets out or posts on instagram
you have croissants and women's rights
damn take me back because france you see
they've got women's rights unlike
america
where in america we won't let you kill
your baby
in some circumstances in america in some
states
in some circumstances you're not allowed
to kill your baby and so jessica biel
who is completely ignorant of pretty
much everything she posts this picture
of france which is this beacon of
liberalism it's leftism that's where we
get the term left in politics comes from
france comes from the french revolution
and she says ah take me back you've got
good food and women's rights
because jessica biel doesn't realize
that france bans abortions after 14
weeks
france has and for a very long time has
had
much more restrictive laws on abortion
than the united states does
but jessica biel doesn't know that
jessica biel doesn't know
she doesn't know what the dobbs decision
is actually going to mean she doesn't
know what the overruling of roe v wade
actually means
she doesn't know what abortion laws are
around the world she doesn't realize
that america is the outlier when it
comes to abortion we're the outlier on
the pro-abortion side
only other countries that have laws as
barbaric when it comes to abortion as
the united states does
are north korea
canada america's hat and china
the other countries are much much more
restrictive
of of abortion
and and it's it's not even entirely
jessica biel's fault i think a lot of
the french don't quite understand this
either i mentioned this at the very end
of the show yesterday
the french for some reason
are in france in front of the eiffel
tower
protesting the american supreme court's
decision to overrule roe v wade
and send the issue of abortion back to
the states
[Applause]
[Music]
just really feeling this protest because
of what has just happened in the united
states
can't believe
our good fortune and it just feels
feels like a lot of solidarity here it's
very special
it feels like a lot of solidarity that's
true that's the only thing you can say
about this they've got signs they're
written in french which is saying it's a
right it's the law
what law last i checked the french are
not uh subject to american law
what and by the way it's not even a
right in your law
french
and by the way the the 14 weeks is a
liberalization of abortion laws
previously it had been 12 weeks or 10
weeks
what do you mean it's a right it's a law
what do you it's the solidarity this
gets to something we were talking about
yesterday too which is this idea of a
liberal world order the biden
administration going on tv saying stop
complaining about gas prices stop
complaining about how your economy is
falling apart we we in america we've got
to defend the liberal world order and
you're going to have to pay for it
this is the liberal world order this is
hegemonic liberalism this is france
viewing itself not as an independent
nation but as a kind of just vassal of
the united states of the american
liberal empire that spreads its
liberal values all around the world and
so there's a sense of solidarity
even when the actual law the actual
constitution of these countries does not
back it up
and this is a massive acceleration these
french pro-abortion activists are not
only out ahead of the french law
they're not only contradicting their own
law
they're they're contradicting the view
of abortion
everywhere in the whole even in the
whole liberal empire even in the united
states until very very recently back in
2015
even back in 2015 seven years ago we
were not living in the shout your
abortion on demand without apology
have have an abortion at the 19th
trimester your
your baby is going to be born in
virginia and then you can make a
decision of whether you want to kill him
or not we weren't there in 2015. in 2015
the current president of the united
states joe biden
then the vice president of the united
states
said that abortion is always wrong
you know there's even been the
disagreement in our church
not that abortion is always wrong
abortion's always wrong
abortion is always wrong so says joe
biden the democrat
then vice president now president of the
united states a mere seven years later
we are at abortion on demand without
apology the court has made its decision
let's see the court enforce it
massive protests in the streets not just
in america but all around the world
biden right now is saying that of all
the things destabilizing the world
the
putin invasion of ukraine the
american complete surrender on energy
policy the collapse of the american and
western economies biden says the the
biggest factor destabilizing the world
overruling roe v wade
the one thing that has been
destabilizing is the outrageous behavior
of the supreme court of the united
states
on overruling not only roe v wade but
essentially challenging the right to
privacy we've been a leader in the world
in terms of personal rights and privacy
rights and it is a mistake
in my view for the supreme court to do
what it did the outrageous behavior of
the of the supreme court to
restore the rule of law and admit that
the most ridiculous decision in american
history that not even the libs defend is
is not a legit decision that's the one
thing destabilizing the world not the
virus that escaped from the laboratory
in wuhan probably not the global
lockdown that that occurred for two
years not the major war in europe for
the first time since world war ii not
the collapse of american energy policy
not the not the not the not the no it's
that the supreme court is allowing the
people of the states to make their own
laws with regard to abortion that's the
most destabilizing thing so says
joe biden why because the united states
has been a leader on the right to
privacy
i can get right now
pull up just google constitution
constitution okay u.s constitution boom
find me the right to privacy
where do you have your constitution
pulled up maybe you're driving don't
don't don't pull over you don't you can
look it up later
where is the right to privacy in the
constitution i feel as though i'm i'm
sitting in a room with joe biden by it's
a padded room i'm a doctor with a
clipboard joe biden is there wearing
wearing some kind of restraint or
harness i say okay mr president this
right to privacy that you're talking
about is um
is that right to privacy in the room
with us now there is no such thing as a
general right to privacy in the
constitution this was something
completely made up by the libs they they
said that it could be found maybe
between the emanations and the penumbras
and invisible links somewhere and one of
the amendments and anyway never mind
that's going to be the law now and it
never made sense and it it really
weakened our judiciary and our our
system of government and the rule of law
in the united states and now it's
falling apart
and they did it because they thought the
ends justified the means and they wanted
a shortcut to contraception and a
shortcut to the sexual revolution and a
shortcut to killing babies and so they
they did that but it was always
ridiculous it was a house of cards now
it's falling apart
and now the whole thing is falling
and so they're all devouring their own
hold up one second we are so close to 1
million subscribers and i know what's
going to happen the minute we get to 999
999 you know youtube's gonna be waiting
on the button they're just gonna wait
and then it's gonna hit a million
they're gonna nuke my entire account but
i don't care let's accelerate this baby
what will b will be subscribe send the
channel to your friends never miss a
notification we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]